in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Desmond
and Portia are with us welcome guys how
are you
good welcome where do you guys live the
Baton Rouge Louisiana alright welcome to
Nashville and your shirt says you're a
youtube crazy yes yes all right very
cool very cool and Desmond your church
says I'm not a chicken that's right I
got to hear about this story but I'm
more wait a second I got it there's got
to be a story to that definitely I must
have called you something so anyway that
could happen here so how much debt have
you all paid off we paid off a hundred
and seventy three thousand three hundred
and twenty seven dollars
Wow and cash flow to $30,000 Murphy and
how long did this take twenty three
months and two weeks that's amazing and
what was your household income during
this time household income was 145 to
165 cool and what do y'all do for a
living
I am a officer in the reserves and also
worked for a fortune 500 company as
operations manager oh wow and Porsha is
retired medical military and
entrepreneur there we go very good cool
so you're killing it well done thank you
for your service what kind of debt was
the 173 and looking at these numbers you
must have sold something through yes so
the bed to step on the air mattress my
husband would ever let me well at the
top of the list $86,000 student loans
Wow gave Sallie Mae her fiction notice
50,000 vehicles 16,000 times share
21,000 and credit cards personal loans
and stupid tax this is everything but
the house so did you sell some cars or
boats or anything my guys we sold I had
a convertible Camaro that I saw
[Music]
it he had a tundra platinum tundra yeah
Bo did you sell table longer yep hold
the boat yeah boat so the custom LSU
tiger print pool table oh they make more
you know what is a custom LSU pool table
bring in Baton Rouge actually it
originally was for $3,000 yeah we sold
it I got it off a Craigslist because I'm
a big ok so I purchased it for $1100 and
I was able to sell it for an 1,100 all
right I've got a help good that's good
that's a substantial deal Wow
so you sold everything and so what are
y'all driving now well I Drive a Toyota
Camry and he has a 4runner
ok not bad you're making 165 thousand
dollars a year and now you're not broke
yeah man y'all went all-in intense for
23 months here people must have thought
you'd lost your mind that's right yeah
yeah because we also downsized from a
3,500 square foot house to 1100 square
foot apartment
oh she sold your house so no we was when
we were Santa by him but then we took
FPU and I was like oh no we need a way
ok you had to clean up now you're ready
to buy tho that's Wow so that's really
well it's great I think you could that's
pretty amazing cool ok so that's what I
hate to ask but why are you not a
chicken
tell me the story you know my wife
probably tells this story better chicken
actually I called in the show about a
situation that we wasn't agreeing on and
we said what every Dave says that's what
we're going to do mm-hmm
and so we agreed to that and so when I
called him you called him a chicken and
said that he wasn't gonna have the
conversation he needed to have the
boundaries discussion
he had to tell somebody he didn't want
to tell no and I said if he doesn't do
that he's a chicken yeah so you had the
conversation so that's why you're not a
chicken that may be scarier than the
boot camp reserves that's awesome man I
love it well now I love this shirt I
need a shirt I'm not a chicken day
that's good that's great now it makes
total sense though that it sounds like
something I would do now that you
described it wow you guys are fired up I
mean did what got you this on fire cuz I
mean you did go nuts in a good way you
got your life back I mean it's got to
feel great does it feel great I mean
you're so enthusiastic that you sold off
all your really killer cars all of your
stuff you move out of the big Taj Mahal
rental house into an apartment and now
you're free but what made you get that
wired up you know I was actually a
volunteer at this nonprofit organization
and there's this guy there he's like
tells everybody about Dave Ramsey listen
to the radio and so yeah I was coming to
Baton Rouge and the class was about to
happen FPU mm-hm and so he was like are
you going to the class are you going to
the class so we signed up for FPU and I
was gone cold from then I was like oh we
got to do this week you know and so
that's what did it
okay and then you just told Desmond
we're going to class yeah and what does
more he was like okay we can do it but
the thing was we had a trip planned to
Disney in December oh yeah so I was like
oh no we need to cancel he was like well
no we could wait and so actually we
prayed and fasted for 40 days whoa for
God to bring us on one Accord because I
I'm kind of extreme that's what he calls
me
I'm just dedicated I'm not extricating
I'm just motivated to get out of day you
know and so that really helped us you
know because on one Accord and yes it is
that's a huge deal
mm-hmm well once you are of one Accord
nothing can stop you exactly nothing can
stop you yeah and you guys you you're a
force to be reckoned with
I mean you'll be able to pay cash for a
house you're gonna be able to do
anything you want to do the rest of your
life the generosity you'll be able to do
you're gonna run into people that need
help and you'll be able to just do it
and I think about it right because
nobody owns you now that's it yeah
you're no longer a slave to the lender
that's right that's pretty impressive
stuff guys Wow very cool so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is oh that's that's a great
question
one thing I can say is you you have to
be committed once you agree to do
something you have to be committed to do
it and and you have to see beyond your
current situation you have to see where
you want to be more than you see where
you are
so once you can see beyond that then you
can start to dream and and there's many
times where we actually drove through
neighborhoods and looked at the nice
houses and say you know when we do this
right we can go pick a house we can do
that you know what we wanted to do it
right you know I hadn't thought about
that sharing I used to do that we would
go drive the rich neighborhood that's
Ango you know some day we could do that
here's what we got that we got do this
this and this and then we can get there
and it wasn't like oh we'll never get
there roll our eyes of those evil rich
people more like I'm gonna be one of you
mm-hmm you know and that's what you do
when you drive that neighborhood I'm
gonna live here I'll live in that one
you know just like that you know right
that's a good I did that too because it
gets it gets down inside of you then
doesn't it it does it does and then you
could sell stupid cars you know and get
you whatever you so stupid boat and get
you one later man cuz exactly you can
live like nobody else later you can live
and give like no one else because you're
not giving up forever that's right if
you think you're giving up that stuff
forever it's real painful to sell all
that stuff that you guys you know you
cleaned house literally I mean mad cuz I
saw the dining-room tables though whoa
we still don't have a dining room table
way get you another one
I think it's healthier to eat standing
up well you guys way to go and your
young men are with you you these are
your sons I take it yes all right and
their names are we have DJ's twelve
years old
and Christians thirteen all right cash
is king debt is dumb their t-shirts say
so well done you guys well we got a copy
of Chris Hogan's retire inspired book
for you that's the next chapter in your
story to be millionaires living in that
house used to drive by right I love it I
love it I love you guys you're all fun
this is great and of course you know
that that's an it'd be outrageously
generous along the way that's what
you're set up for Desmond Porsche
Christian and DJ Baton Rouge Louisiana
one hundred and seventy three thousand
dollars paid off cash flow to another
thirty did it in twenty three months
they sold everything in sight they are
free a hundred and forty five thousand
up two hundred and sixty five thousand
dollar income counted down
let's hear a debt free scream one two
ready sing
job you guys that's fun and that's a
blast by the way I'm not calling people
on YouTube crazy they self named
themselves to people watching this show
on YouTube everyday lives they self name
themselves the YouTube crazies might
have been Ken Coleman involved in that
too
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]